[JINGLE PLAYING]
ANDREW MCMAHON: This
is a tune that kind of
kicked off the "Upside Down
Flowers" writing process
for me.
It's a song about a trip I
took with my family crossing
the country, moving from the
Midwest to the West Coast.
It's called Ohio.
[ANDREW MCMAHON SINGING "OHIO"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
This is cool.
When I got this
invitation, I was like,
what would Google
want to do with me?
But I'm glad.
I'm glad that you
all invited us out.
I've had a good
few days in Boston.
I got to play House of Blues
last night, which was a blast.
What do you think?
Should we do "Fire Escape?"
It's an early--
This is rock and roll morning,
just so you guys know.
So let's get the high notes
out of the way, see how we do.
This is about a long weekend
in New York City, where there
wasn't much sleep going on.
It's called "Fire Escape."
[ANDREW MCMAHON SINGING "FIRE
ESCAPE"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
ZAC CLARK: It's a fine
cappuccino bar you have here.
I must say.
ANDREW MCMAHON: Yeah, I mean, I
would be so jacked on caffeine
if there was a free latte
every time I turned a corner.
ZAC CLARK: After my
second cappuccino,
I applied for a job.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
--put in a good word for me.
ANDREW MCMAHON:
Yeah, so, Bob and Zac
both have been talking
about how they're putting
in their applications today.
I'm not sure.
At least your schooling will get
you further than the cafeteria.
I certainly know mine wouldn't.
I'm just kidding.
Bobby went to way more
school than I did.
And Zac is--
BOBBY ANDERSON: It seems
like the happiest place
on earth, after the
cafeteria experience, too.
ANDREW MCMAHON: There's a
burrito waiting for them
in the dressing room.
This is Bobby Raw Anderson
here on the guitar,
Mr. Zac Clark on the keys.
I figured we'd do
another new song.
This is probably one of my
favorites off of the new album.
I think doing what we do
for a living every day,
you kind of wake up and it's
a little bit of a gamble.
Maybe this music business will
be here for us tomorrow or not.
But I think, as I've
been very fortunate to do
this for 18 years in
three different bands,
I should probably stop
asking that question
and just enjoy it.
That's what my wife tells me.
So this one's
called "Paper Rain."
[ANDREW MCMAHON SINGING "PAPER
RAIN"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So the last tune we'll do for
you is a song that I wrote,
gosh, 2014, I guess, maybe?
It was right before
my daughter was born.
I ended up in this writing
session with two guys
I'd never met before.
But that a of my publisher
said these guys are great.
You should hang out.
And I had to kind of give the
caveat, when I was on my way
up to the session,
like, my wife is
within weeks of giving birth.
I may end up having to leave
at some point in the middle
of this little session.
And it sort of
became the decision,
when we walked
into the room, OK,
well, let's just write that.
Let's write a song for
this new kid that's
going to come into your world.
And that song changed a
lot for me, which is crazy.
I've done this for a lot
of years, like I mentioned.
I've played in a lot of bands.
And I sort of wrote
this song as, like,
a introduction of myself
to my soon-to-be baby girl.
And interestingly enough,
for a lot of people
it became the introduction to
me as an artist altogether.
Because it was
really the first song
I ever had that got
substantial radio play
and a lot of exposure on.
So she's a good luck charm
for more reasons than one.
And she turned five last
week, which is crazy to me.
But yeah, so this one is called
"Cecilia and The Satellite."
[ARTIST SINGING "CECILIA AND THE
SATELLITE"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.
Bob and Zac, one more
time, thank you, guys.
ZAC CLARK: Put in
a good word for us
in the application process.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW MCMAHON: For
the record, they both
have much higher
education than I do.
SPEAKER: I'll get right to
work on your job applications.
Yeah.
So I wanted to talk to you
a bit about the inspiration
for your album, which has one
of the coolest album titles,
I think--
"Upside Down Flowers."
So I was reading on your site.
You said that you called it
that because, in many ways,
it's a mirror to my world--
an uncanny reflection, but
not quite the real thing.
Could you talk a little bit
more about that uncanny nature
of reality?
ANDREW MCMAHON: Yeah.
You know, what's interesting
about the genesis
of this record was that a lot
of times you start records
and you know you're
starting a record,
or you know you're
in the process.
And instead, with this
album, I had this rare moment
where, after two full records
of touring and creating,
I had a few months off at home.
Which is something that,
since I started this project,
I had not had in a while.
And the process began with--
I watched this
documentary, "Abstract."
Which I don't know if you guys
have seen this on Netflix,
but it's a documentary
about just creatives
and the different
threads of success
through their creative lives.
And the one thing
that struck me--
and I've always
known to be true,
but it's easy sometimes to
forget when you are an artist
who tours like we do--
that you've got to put
yourself in the position
to create every day.
And when I got home and
I had this block of time,
I think usually what I might do
is take a couple weeks and just
sort of flounder and
hang out with the family
and see old friends.
And I did all that.
But my daughter was
finally school age.
So I started working in
the back house studio where
I wrote this record and
just created my own writing
practice based around the day.
And what ended up creeping
up were a combination
of these memories--
like the one you heard in
"Ohio," which is very much,
in a way, a kind of a vivid
portrayal of something
that happened to me when I was
a kid to a song like "Paper
Rain," which was, I
think, true in some senses
philosophically, about
this idea of living life
as a bit of a gamble.
But it was very much
a story that kind of
came to me in the middle
of that writing process
and became the story
of somebody else.
But somehow, a piece
of me existed in there,
if that makes sense.
SPEAKER: Yeah, definitely.
I found "Ohio" very moving,
both figuratively and literally,
as it talks about your move
from Ohio to California.
And I know you referred to it
as sort of a pilgrimage for you.
So what did that mean
for you as a child,
moving from the Midwest out
to the land where it's always
sunny and warm and all that?
ANDREW MCMAHON: Yeah.
I mean, admittedly
my family-- we were
all in a bit of a tricky time.
Around then, I was about
11 or 12 years old.
And we had sort of gone
on the roller coaster
of having done
very well, and then
had kind of lost
everything to some extent.
And we had family
on the West Coast.
It was, like, those were
the cousins we always went
to visit in the summertime.
You know?
And that was a great summer.
Every summer, you're like, oh!
I grew up kind of
Midwest, East Coast,
where we could go to
California for the summers.
And in a sense, it always felt
like the promised land to me,
you know?
And when we found
ourselves with so little,
it just made sense to go
be with my mom's family
on the West Coast.
And I think, for me, as
hard as that time was,
and for my family,
as hard as it was,
it was where we sort
of rebuilt our lives
and built a new
story for ourselves.
And for me, it was
the place where
I was able to really
explore my songwriting.
I had written for years
prior to our move there.
But this was the place
where I built my first band.
I found those kind
of close friends
that, when you're somebody
who moves every three
years as a kid, you don't get
to make those close connections.
And I think it did feel, and
it still does to this day,
it's not my native home.
But it's about as native
feeling as I know--
is the beach towns of
Southern California.
SPEAKER: So like a lot
of people, probably,
in the audience, my
favorite song of yours
is "Cecilia and The Satellite",
which you just played.
And you give a little bit
of the background in it.
But it's such a
beautiful love song.
But what's, I think,
so special about it
is we don't hear a whole
lot of rock love songs
from parents to children.
It's usually a different kind
of romantic type of song.
So I was wondering if you'd
talk a little bit more
about the genesis
and also how does
your daughter feel about it?
Do you play it for her a
lot, that sort of thing?
ANDREW MCMAHON: Any song that
references her-- my daughter
is a huge fan of.
I'm sure that is going to change
within the next four or five
years.
But as of now, I mean, even
on, like, even on "Paper Rain",
there's that lyric,
you know? (SINGING)
I've got mouths to feed, I'm
going to get-- (SPEAKING)
--but my daughter goes, that's
my mouth you have to feed.
You're, like,
thank you, Cecilia.
Yeah, she knows.
She's keenly aware of where
she fits into my catalog now.
Yeah.
For me, and I'm sure we can
touch on this at some point,
you know, "Cecilia" is a
product of a very tricky time
in my life.
I'm a cancer survivor.
And you know, I was sort
of rendered infertile
as a part of that treatment.
I apologize to get a little
gross here for you all.
But there's this
kind of joking story
that I've told, if you've
been to one of my shows.
It's not really a joke.
It's true.
That in the process of
being a sick person,
finding out that you're going
to be infertile, at least,
for me--
I was lucky to have
a doctor to say
you've got to bank your sperm.
And that's going to-- maybe
one day you'll have a family.
And I was, like, I don't care.
I was 22 at the time.
I was just-- that's not really
of interest to me right now.
Let's load me up with
the chemo, whatever,
and let's kill this cancer.
And eventually, what ended up
happening was he was, like,
I won't treat you if
you don't do this.
So I did.
And you know,
miraculously, years pass.
And my wife and I
got to this place
where, like, we do
want to have a kid.
And we went through
this IVF process.
And I met this little person.
And I think, in a weird way,
telling that story and meeting
my daughter was the thing
that kind of closed the loop
on my cancer experience.
Because I met the most
important person in my life,
or one of them, because
of that experience.
And so I think when I
was writing that song,
I felt all of those things.
That's why, instead of it
becoming just an ordinary love
song, it really became
me trying to educate
my daughter on the person I had
been, the things that I'd seen,
and let her know that those
peaks and valleys in life
are going to come to us all.
But also that my
hope is that I could
be there to walk that
road with her as much
as humanly possible.
And I love that it
became my biggest song.
Because there are oftentimes
people in this business
that will try and force you into
the lowest common denominator
to reach the most
amount of people.
And what I found is
historically what's
been successful for
me has been the most
specificity and the most
sort of leaning into my story
and trying to find
those tangible threads.
Those universal threads have
been what have kind of led me
to the largest audience.
SPEAKER: Yeah, I think there's
a lot of truth to that.
That when you get
more specific, it
becomes universal at the
same time sometimes, too.
So I can't imagine what
that was like, getting
a cancer diagnosis that young.
And I'm sure that
that greatly impacted
not just your life, but the
trajectory of your career.
Just in terms of going
through that experience,
being a survivor, do you feel
like that has affected like all
of the music you wrote since?
ANDREW MCMAHON: Yeah.
I mean, I think the dangerous
game of survivorship
is trying to look at your
life as these sliding doors,
you know?
And saying, well, gosh,
if that hadn't happened,
where would I be now?
And I think it's
taken me years to sort
of unlearn that mentality.
And say, well, this did happen.
You know, this is the
way that your life went.
You know?
But it took me a lot
of years to figure out,
just as you build good
memories on the other side
of some trauma, that
becomes your life.
And that can be a really
beautiful existence.
But certainly it worked its
way into my creative process.
It worked its way, and
it was hard to create
after being sick.
I went from being
this fearless--
you know, I made these records,
and I'd gotten successful
at such a young age, that
all of a sudden now I
had this ghost in every room
with me, going, you know?
Every decision became
much trickier to make.
It was, like, everything
became life or death
after seeing life and death
in that frame at a young age.
But it's taught me a lot.
And at this point,
I wouldn't trade it.
So much, like I said, has
happened because of it.
And I've been able to
make a lot of change
and try and raise a
lot of money for people
who've been in my position.
And that's been really
rewarding work for me.
SPEAKER: You're definitely an
inspiration to a lot of people,
having gone through
that and continuing
to create afterwards.
So on a lighter note,
I learned that you're
an amateur mixologist.
You just kicked off
a new video series
on YouTube, "The Rocktail Hour."
Could you talk a bit
about that, your interest
in cocktails and your hobbies?
ANDREW MCMAHON: Yeah.
I mean, I got a buzz
on at home one night.
And these phones,
as we all know,
sometimes you'll
maybe shoot a video
that you shouldn't shoot when
you've had too much to drink.
And I think it was a margarita.
I have a house margarita I make.
Then I was just, like, all
right, kids, here we go.
You know?
And it just turned into
this thing for my fans.
They loved that window
into to my world.
And I think that that's a lesson
learned for me as somebody
who is not a early
adopter of technology,
but somebody who very much
has to be thrust and forced.
Like, my manager's going, you
need to post on Instagram.
And now I do.
And I love that stuff.
But yes, we started this series.
A buddy of mine has a
bar in town where I live.
And he wrote all those recipes
and was behind the camera
going, now you do this.
Now you do that.
I make, like, three drinks well
and then quickly forget them.
But yeah.
It's fun.
It's a nice meditation at
the end of the night for me
to just make a single
drink for myself and enjoy.
SPEAKER: We have some time
for audience questions,
if anybody wants to come up
to the mic and ask questions.
AUDIENCE: First off, thank
you so much for joining us.
As one of your fans who loves
a little bit of a window
into your life and the creative
process, much appreciated.
ANDREW MCMAHON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You talk
about how you've
been on all these different
projects and bands
and you've gone through
a lot of life changes.
You talked earlier about being
a 22-year-old kid who, you know,
whatever.
I don't care about a
sperm bank right now.
Just treat me.
Obviously, your creative process
and style and musical style
has changed a lot
over those years.
Who you are has changed
a lot over those years.
As a musician, though,
the music that you've made
is permanent, right?
It's on record.
And there's some expectation
that you perform that old music
from time to time.
What is that like for you
being a very different person
than that person that
wrote those old songs?
ANDREW MCMAHON: Yeah.
You know, it's interesting.
I look at all of the
chapters of my first band,
Something Corporate, Jack's
Mannequin, this record.
I don't necessarily look at
them as different people-- maybe
different lives, to some
extent, or different chapters
of a life.
And sure there are some
songs from my back catalog
that maybe I don't favor.
I would rather not play.
But what's interesting is I find
that the ones that are enduring
and the ones that people
talk about the most,
those are the ones that
matter to me the most.
Kind of speaking to this idea
of when you write something that
feels very true
to yourself, even
if it's in some sort
of fledgling state
or some moment of growth, those
things still feel relevant.
You know, when I play
those songs, and we do--
we do quite a bit of
back catalog in my set,
it's always kind of a
combination of the newest
record--
certainly I try and
lean heavy on whatever
project I'm working
specifically,
so there's a lot of
Wilderness songs in the set.
But the other half
of the set is kind
of a mash up of the bigger
songs from Jack's and Something
Corporate.
And then sort of the ones on the
outskirts that I like the most,
or that fans talk
about the most.
And playing them live--
it still feels good.
If it doesn't, then I generally
kind of jettison those.
Or I try and find
different ways.
There's a song called
"Punk Rock Princess"
from when I was in high school.
You know?
And we're doing it with a
full band for the first time
in forever.
Because this record
and this tour
is sort of a bit of a nostalgia
bent, because the album
itself is so reflective.
But with that song, I've
been doing that as a ballad
on and off for the
last few years.
And as a ballad, I feel like
the earnestness of being young
and what it is to sort
of pursue somebody
who doesn't like the
same music that you like,
which I think is a--
you know, I can still
identify with that somehow.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANDREW MCMAHON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: That guy sort
of stole my question.
But it's more about
just your evolution
of music over the years.
I mean, I feel like there's
pieces that seem very Something
Corporate-y.
But then, obviously,
you've changed a lot
through life
experiences, et cetera.
I'm just curious
how what you learned
and what you experienced
in the Something
Corporate days, how
that impacted you
when it went to Jack's Mannequin
and now your solo career,
what pieces you took with
you, what you maybe discarded.
Do you miss that period of time?
And then what's next?
What's next on your kind of
trajectory here with music?
ANDREW MCMAHON: Yeah.
I mean, well, to the first
part, I think, like any of us,
we're trying to evolve.
And I think that's
been my biggest target.
Just don't settle
and don't stay.
And that's why I've continued
to change project names.
And people kind of hate
me for it on some level.
Because they're,
like, oh, new band?
OK.
But historically,
most of the time,
I have a lot of the same players
or producers or whatever.
We're all involved
in this thing.
And it's just more about
delineating time for me.
The thing that I take from
the Something Corporate era
for me is just I think
about collaboration.
I wasn't a great
collaborator in those days.
I think I was a very guarded
collaborator when I started.
You know, you're a
kid in high school.
And you and your best
friends, you know,
you're making a record together.
And all of a sudden
then it blows up.
And then it gets political,
or whatever it is.
And I'm still close
with all those guys,
because I think we did
what a lot of bands
and a lot of our
contemporaries didn't do,
which-- they stayed in it long
enough to hate each other,
you know?
Where it's, like, we did
the most mature thing
we could have.
Which was, like,
we're best friends,
we're not getting along so
well, let's take a break.
And I think what I've
tried to learn over time,
and I think really
in a large way what
the Wilderness is
a reflection of,
is how in those first two
projects, Something Corporate
and Jack's, I could carry a
chip on my shoulder, which
is just not a healthy way to try
and create or build anything.
You know?
If something didn't
go right or the launch
of an album or a
single didn't take,
I would be pointing fingers.
And with collaboration,
again, I was a little bit more
of a jealous collaborator.
I was always guarded.
And with this project, it really
became about opening myself up.
Not being afraid
to get in a room
and write with somebody
who I admired or respected,
not being afraid to
travel here or there,
or meet this producer, or listen
to what a trusted manager had
to say about a song.
Because they want
me to win, you know?
And I think those are
the big lessons of now.
And I think a lot of that is
just age and getting older.
And saying do you want to walk
through life with your fists
up all the time, or do you
want to sort of move through it
in a peaceful way?
And I'd say those
are the big lessons
I learned from the early days.
As far as what's next,
I'm not 100% sure.
I'm in that bizarre
flux moment now where
this tour feels like it's doing
an amazing job of rounding out
this project.
I don't think I'm walking
away from this project.
But there's some
talk about maybe
doing some scoring work and
some film and television
stuff when I get home.
And I'm working on some other
projects for people who are not
just myself, but
actually contributing
to some other
avenues creatively.
So time will tell.
But I'll always be making songs.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thanks.
Thanks for coming by.
ANDREW MCMAHON: Cheers.
Thank you, appreciate it.
AUDIENCE: My friend
introduced me to your music,
like, 15, 16 years ago.
And my girlfriend, it was
one of our first dates--
went to your show.
ANDREW MCMAHON: Really?
Where?
AUDIENCE: I think it was--
I can't remember.
ANDREW MCMAHON: Was it
in the area, though?
AUDIENCE: It was
in Boston, yeah.
ANDREW MCMAHON: OK, cool.
Awesome.
AUDIENCE: And we've been
married now for 10 years,
and we've got three kids.
My seven-year-old daughter-- her
favorite song is "Fire Escape."
ANDREW MCMAHON: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: And we sing it
to her almost every night.
But the question I want to ask
is, my son is 11 years old.
And he's getting
into music a lot.
He's taking piano
lessons and guitar.
What advice would you give
to the parent of someone who
really wants to get into music?
ANDREW MCMAHON: The best advice
that I can give at this point
is to do what my parents did.
Which, you know, my
parents just supported me.
They never really
drove the whole--
you have to go to lessons.
I eventually asked for
lessons, because I was writing.
And I started by writing.
I learned a couple chords
and that was the beginning
of my writing adventure.
And then after about
a year of that,
I couldn't make any new sounds
or shapes with my fingers.
And so I asked for lessons.
I mean, they were diligent
about trying to make sure I went
and that I didn't
waste their money.
But I think about my mom.
Like, when I started
writing songs,
all the other kids
were playing sports.
You know, what I mean?
And my oldest-- I'm the
youngest of five-- all
of my older brothers and
sisters were great athletes.
I was not a good athlete.
And instead, my parents
saw that I had a passion,
and they backed it.
And you know, my mom
looked up music producer
in the yellow pages
when I was 10 years old
and drove me to Dayton, Ohio.
And I worked in this guy's
little home studio, which
was a fairly new
thing at that point,
and made a three song demo tape.
And it wasn't very good.
But they sort of always
believed in me, you know?
And believed that
it was possible,
when other people were,
like, oh, your kid's
going to be in a band.
And when I was not
gearing up for college,
I think there was
a lot of judgment
there from other parents.
And they just said this is his
passion, and they backed it.
You know, I just would
say with anything, music
or otherwise, if your kid's
got a passion for something--
you know, I learned a lot
from my parents in that sense.
They backed me 100%.
And let him learn songs
he wants to learn.
That's what I would say.
It's important
that they can make
the connection of why
they're learning music
to why they love music.
and sometimes classical
is a great teaching tool.
But I'd say what I did was
every classical song I learned,
I learned a Billy Joel tune.
And I made my teacher do that.
And she was this
scary, scary woman,
and somehow she
still let me do it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANDREW MCMAHON: Cheers.
SPEAKER: Thanks so much
for everyone for coming.
Go buy his album,
"Upside Down Flowers"
or listen to it
on YouTube music,
or your favorite
subscription service.
And thanks again.
ANDREW MCMAHON: Thank you.
I appreciate you.
[APPLAUSE]